the largest water user on the Colorado
River you're continuing to use all the
water we're yeah and we had that right
from water intensive agriculture in
Imperial Valley so we can agree there's
a long way to go
a long way to go we've made good
progress to a lack of water recycling in
their biggest city and why aren't they
taking advantage of the ocean we look at
if California's water Hogs are being
wasteful with our most precious resource
thanks for joining us I'm Kyle Payne
Nevada is a leader in saving water
especially as the Colorado River deals
with drought the largest water user on
the river is California this special
will look at their water use and if they
are doing enough or are water hugs
the Imperial Valley in Southern
California is one of the major
Battlegrounds in the war over the
Colorado River Farmers there use about a
quarter of that precious resource that
area has the most senior water rides
along all 1450 miles of the Colorado
River and they're not planning on
loosening their grip on those rights
anytime soon
it's a lot of the river the law of the
river according to this Farmer in the
Imperial Valley the law of the river
says the farmers come first like it or
not it's hurtful to hear that what we're
doing is a waste of water and we're the
problem the problem is far older than
this fourth generation farmer Andrew
lime Gruber we've had this issue for
longer than I've been alive who seems
like part gatekeeper if you look at our
priority system it was based on first in
line first in use and part politician
you know you made the comment that I
sound like a politician well it's
because I've had to as Farmers we have
to wear many hats I have to to tell my
story because there's no one else to
tell it so he tells it like it is I hate
where the conversation is Led he's done
many interviews like this one where he's
portrayed as somewhat of a bad guy he
says no one ever mentions the good stuff
like how Imperial Valley Farmers have in
the last 20 years spent some half a
billion dollars on conversion systems
and saved a total of just under a
million acre feet of water per year
roughly enough water to service two and
a half million homes we have drip
systems sprinkler systems tail water
recovery systems he says Farmers there
have changed the orientation of the
fields to conserve water and then
they've lined dirt ditches with cement
and created reservoirs to catch water
that would otherwise be lost could you
be conserving more
well yeah that's uh that's the question
of the day is can we be conserving more
Robert shutler works for the Imperial
Irrigation District one of his jobs is
to write the mission statement and
vision for the district it's important
for us to protect the river and to
defend the farmers you're continuing to
use all the water we're yeah uh well and
we had that right that right even
extends to the massive overwhelming
amount of water these farmers use to
produce Alfalfa that leafy crop that
feeds the cows and feeds you and me and
a lot of the areas that farm along the
Colorado River Feed The Nation but at
what cause it makes them big money and
uses a ton of water in comparison an
eight-minute shower uses 20 gallons of
water while one bale of alfalfa drinks
up 650 gallons but the farmers say they
use all this water because the public
demands it the real question is is
growing the food supply for the nation a
beneficial use of water beneficial use
the long-standing basic principle
defining California water rights which
limits water use to what's quote
reasonably required and prohibits waste
that there's a new definition of what
constitutes a beneficial use of water
bill hazenkamp manages the Colorado
River resources for Southern
California's Metropolitan water district
unfettered growing of Alfalfa in the
desert might not be a beneficial use
it's not a beneficial use for me to
plant thousands of Acres of quinoa if
there's not a market for it and even in
the face of the river drying up and the
highest temps and worst drought in
centuries the farmers aren't budging
particularly because if they can't Farm
their livelihood will go down the drain
why would we solve a Water Crisis and
then create a food crisis some farming
areas are dealing with the crisis in a
different way they're taking the
government up on its offer to let
fertile Fields go unplanted in exchange
for what amounts to hundreds of millions
of dollars it's a big thing here in
Blythe California about 200 miles south
of Las Vegas you can see it's dusty and
dry here and economies in some areas
that take the money also take a big hit
and that has everyone caught up in this
war on water saying the f word for us
that's the f word in the valley
following following is when Farmland is
allowed to lie idle during the growing
season the land basically stays bone dry
because there's no reason to water it
thus preserving some of the Colorado
River Supply but the choice to fallow is
just that a choice when it comes to
Colorado River water the farmer's cup
runneth over without the change in
legislation change in law we have to
work with them to incentivize them to
reduce
so for now until California and the
other six states that rely on Colorado
River water come to an agreement the
water in the desert will flood the
fields and to the Chagrin of most
southern Nevada the Alfalfa will
flourish and continue to fatten up the
food supply Nevada has been one of the
most vocal places against the growing of
Alfalfa and farming in the desert in
general but I guarantee you if you go to
the Rio buffet right now and you look at
their salad bar that produce is grown
right here so it's a little hypocritical
for them to call for the ending of
farming in the desert and then to
benefit off of the bounty it produces
Southern nevadans are hypocrites
I must say he was a very good sport and
was up for the debate and I thought you
our viewers would appreciate his Candor
in a few places they've been recycling
water even Wastewater for decades here
in southern Nevada they say every drop
of water that hits a drain pipe gets
recycled in Los Angeles that number is
only two percent but in California they
have more psychic options storm water
sea water and yes sewage water the
question is are they recycling it or
wasting it
what these seagulls and Ducks here in
South La probably don't know is the
water on which they Frolic and above
which they fly fills this man-made lake
in a park dedicated by a living legend
struggle for our community and Magic
Johnson Park named after the legendary
LA Laker has a pretty interesting Lake
of its own right here alongside the
playgrounds and walking trails the
scientists and Engineers are using this
intricate Maze of machines to treat and
reuse storm water and then the water
gets diverted here where it gets treated
with ozone Alum and um chlorine what
this all means is they're trapping storm
water that would otherwise be unused and
reuse it to water the park seems like a
pittance
a a single Park might seem like a
pittance but it's a step in the right
direction inevitably the direction of
the water recycling conversation leads
somewhere some Californians aren't quite
ready for and that's the idea of taking
Wastewater treat it to high quality
standards safe enough for the public
Jesus Gonzalez is the manager of
recycled water policy for LA's
Department of Water and Power where
there are four wastewater treatment
plants serving some big commercial
customers about 4 billion gallons of
water a year and their 20 to 30 year
plans indicate that number should be
considerably higher so we can agree
there's a long way to go a long way to
go we made good progress the
conversation about water recycling has
landed at the doorstep of many a
courthouse where legal battles have
waged on for years but what's going on
here at the Santa Monica Courthouse has
nothing to do with the law it's got
everything to do with What Lies Beneath
that's kind of the mo of our industry is
out of sight out of mind out of sight
definitely hidden here underneath this
parking lot in downtown Santa Monica
where this first of its kind 96 million
dollar recycling plant leverages all
sorts of water including Municipal
Wastewater to make a drought resilient
Supply hoping to rely on their own
recycled water and not Colorado River
water but when it comes to recycled
Wastewater there's always the so-called
toilet to tap the ick Factor ick factor
it's gone away gone away towards
supplementing Mother Nature with
technology Wang says that and millions
of gallons of recycled water every day
in the grand scheme of the massive
drought along the Colorado River though
a million gallons is barely a drop in
the proverbial bucket you look at that
as a small drop in the bucket but if
everybody does wine you keep adding that
one up it becomes a much larger number
to help somebody water has value even if
it's Wastewater bill hazenkamp is the
manager of Colorado River resources for
the Metropolitan water district which
provides water to 19 million Southern
Californians he says Southern nevadans
who Pride themselves on recycling almost
100 percent of their Wastewater have a
leg up on California because once sewer
water or storm water makes it to the
Pacific Ocean it's gone for good unlike
Las Vegas where the Wastewater flows
back into Lake Mead it's automatically
recycled recycled automatically or
otherwise hazenkamp says using the water
twice or even three times is necessary
because the law water situation is dire
with Lake Powell and Lake Mead at their
lowest levels ever that's bad it's
really bad this is an overwhelming
Endeavor it's an overwhelming Endeavor
it's an Endeavor the engineers at La
water and power are trying to solve
spending billions of dollars over the
next 10 to 20 years on small projects
like Magic Johnson Park and other much
larger projects along the same lines but
it's not easy do you think in our
lifetimes we'll see this water problem
solved
good one
the mwd did tell eight news now that
they're in the early stages of working
on the largest single recycling of water
project in the country
an ocean of water at their disposal
and generally California likes to
protect their Coastline likes to protect
their beaches next to California Water
Hogs with hundreds of miles of Coastline
why is it more being done with
desalination plants we will be right
back
welcome back to our special California
Water hugs saltwater and Southern Nevada
not too often those words get uttered in
the same breath but for our neighbors
just to the West in California it's a
different story that Coast is 840 miles
long but not too much of is being used
to solve the war over Colorado River
water in San Diego 10 in Los Angeles the
number is zero it's most expensive in
California residents are not
enthusiastic about disrupting their
beaches and shorelines
growing up it was you know drought was
the way of life having grown up in Las
Vegas and spending her entire adult life
in Southern California and moved out to
San Diego
environmental engineer Michelle Peters
knows the deal it's very complicated I
definitely understand the
more from the residential
and as the technical compliance manager
for the giant water treatment plant
developer Poseidon at this desalination
plant in Carlsbad right across the
street from This Magnificent Beach where
the Deep Blue Pacific seems to go on
forever Peters knows people in Las Vegas
are tired of waiting for California to
start using some of that beautiful ocean
water to help alleviate the crisis on
the Colorado River I understand a decent
amount on on each side the Carlsbad
plant is an impressive network of pipes
and Potions tubing and tanks we're
producing some of the highest quality
drought proof water providing 10 and the
San Diego readers water supply here but
getting a desalination plant funded
permitted and passed the scrutiny of the
neighbors is not always a breeze just
ask the people here in Huntington Beach
who have been battling for decades about
putting one on this industrial site
that's never going to happen here
Huntington Beach is one of just a
handful of proposed desalination sites
in California one day they're building
and one day they're not in fact there's
only a dozen existing diesel facilities
in the entire state which amounts to
less than one desalination plan for
every 3 million people in California
getting the Carlsbad plan to where it is
today was well no day at the beach
considering it took almost 20 years to
get it permitted
it's a process they're very familiar
with in the lovely Oceanside City of
Dana Point where another engineer the
Project's general manager rich shintaku
is hoping the South Coast Water
District's proposed desalination plant
holds water well the Project's going
pretty well pretty well maybe but you
can hear the hesitation in shintaku's
voice that's because among other things
the area around Dana Point is vulnerable
to earthquakes and if the ground would
have Shake too much it would rupture
their Pipeline and the whole project
would be sunk this project cost 140
million dollars just to get started
and they expect it to cost six million
dollars a year just to run the plan if
it comes to fruition as expected in 2028
and that's why we need to provide a
local drinking water solution shintaku
has been in the water business for 30
years early in his career his job was to
keep track of the Colorado River it's a
very very large problem and that's
that's an understatement right right
which is why Southern nevadans want more
results but these desalination plants
are expensive and a hard sell for most
Californians and generally California
likes to protect their Coastline like
stick protect their beaches bill
hazenkamp is the manager of Colorado
resources for the Metropolitan water
district which supplies water to some 19
million Southern Californians he says
between the high price of building these
plants getting Coastal commission
approval and having to build unsightly
plants on gorgeous waterfront real
estate so these house a piece of the
puzzle but it's not going to solve all
the problems
the officials we spoke with about
desalination made sure to tell us that
water reuse and recycling was a far less
expensive less controversial and less
time consuming option than desalination
still in Los Angeles for instance only
two percent of their water supply is
recycled
to make sure you have enough water you
have to store it
yeah we aren't building new dams but
we're we're retrofitting the dams to
make sure that they can capture as much
as possible up next we look at the dams
are
dams in our neighborhoods to the west
and if they're doing enough to save
water
there has been record rainfall in
California this year it would be nice to
know that some of that storm water might
alleviate the crisis on the Colorado
River but Statewide they haven't built a
dam in California in around 40 years we
went in search of answers in California
but ended up way up in the mountains
this captured storm water made its way
down from the tip top of these mountains
the San Gabriel mountains in Los Angeles
County into this storage Basin and when
it's time it comes rushing and gushing
through this opening in the 92 year old
big Tujunga Dam where the water flows
from here and into an intricate network
of spreading basins and floods out for
municipal use in Los Angeles a man-made
Marvel in the middle of Mother Nature
they're still standing today and
functioning as they were intended
Sterling Capel works for LA County as
their head of stormwater engineering you
can see his whole face light up when he
tells you his story about La County's 14
major dams this is a story that a lot of
people don't understand but here it's
been very Visionary going back to the
20s and 30s but that was then yeah we
aren't building new dams but we're we're
retrofitting the dams to make sure that
they could capture as much as possible
the Big Canyon reservoir behind me looks
empty it's not it's just covered
protecting the water supply fly here in
Corona del Mar overlooking Newport Beach
California but its appearance is
emblematic in one of the knocks against
what the state does or doesn't do to
collect and store water especially
considering they haven't built a dam or
Reservoir here more or less in 40 years
there's nowhere to build and we got dams
in the places that need they need to be
they say every major river in California
is damned so instead of new dams and
reservoirs California and its cities and
towns are trying out other options like
storing water underground but we had to
be creative in coming up with it rather
than building new dance bill hazenkamp
is the manager of Colorado River
resources for the Metropolitan water
district which provides water to 19
million Southern Californians he says
storage Deans vary in California
depending on whether they're having a
wet year or a dry year 2023 is a wet
year with double the normal rainfall
2017 and 2019 were also wet but 2018
2020 21 and 22 were all dry in dry years
the MW WD needs to tap into its stash
like they did last year the years before
that Metropolitan added water to Lake
Mead every year but all across
California the water storage game isn't
going so well within the last month the
state's largest reservoirs are nearing
their storage limit and most are above
the amount they historically store an
embarrassment of riches for the time
being at least so what we need is that
storage to carry water over from one wet
year to the subsequent dry years that
isn't an easy task and faced with tough
questions about Southern California
being a villain in the war on Colorado
River water so I think we we have done a
great job of changing that imagery
across California and across the western
states La Department of Water and Sewer
wanted to make sure we got the full
story on how they do water including
water storage Terence McCarthy is
ladwp's manager of water resources
policy so I did want to convey all of
the efforts we've made through the
decades on water conservation McCarthy
says in La the demand for water hasn't
changed despite the population growing
over a million people in the last 40
years we've been continuing to develop
our local supplies ever since the 1970s
the 1970s
right around the last time a major
dammer reservoir was built in California
dams like big Tujunga a goodie even if
it's an oldie we knew even back then
that water was a precious commodity and
water's life
we'll be right back
one theme I heard throughout my visit to
California is that water is life all the
states along the Colorado River
acknowledge they will have to make
changes to how they use water that may
include growing different crops in the
desert doing more water recycling or
even increasing the use of desalination
thank you for watching we will stay on
top of any developments keep an eye on
8newsnow.com
[Music]
please